[Musik]
heute soll es um ein thema gehen dass
ich nur auf den ersten blick etwas von
der aktualität entfernt um die frage
nämlich welchen effekt der russische
angriffskrieg auf die westliche kunst
und insbesondere musikwelt hat immer
mehr westliche opern und konzerthäuser
canceln russischstämmige musiker
streichen russische musik aus ihren
spielplänen der fall anna netrebko hat
dabei besondere aufmerksamkeit erfahren
dazu spreche ich gleich mit unserem faz
musikexperten ihre nachbarn genauso mit
unserer tanz kritikerin gibt gerüchte
über den rücktritt des chefs des
bayerischen staatsballetts die frage
wieviel gesinnungsprüfung eine
öffentlichkeit vom russischstämmigen
künstlern gerade verlangen kann treibt
nicht nur fachkreisen als der
ukrainische botschafter andrej melik vor
einigen tagen öffentlichkeitswirksam
seine teilnahme an einem benefiz konzert
der berliner philharmoniker im schloss
bellevue absagte weil dabei russische
solisten spielten erregte das großes
aufsehen dass ein interview und
tagesspiegel indem er bundespräsident
steinmeier beschuldigte mit eben diesem
konzert für putin zitat die stellung zu
halten hat noch höhere wellen geschlagen
die stimmen mehren sich diesen lauten
und rücksichtslos sprechen denn man
sitzt diplomatie für untragbar halten
ich habe am ende dieses faz podcasts für
deutschland die chance darüber mit
botschafter wenig persönlich zu sprechen
heute ist mittwoch der sechste april ein
name ist simon strauß und es ist gut
dass sie dabei sind
[Musik]
wenn wir hier im hintergrund hören das
ist der junge russische pianist andreas
henke und zwar beim stil eines préludes
von rachmaninow ob er dieses sanfte
stück auch in zukunft noch spielen wird
es plötzlich zu einer heiß diskutierten
politischen frage geworden ich freue
mich dass ich jetzt mit dem pianisten
selber darüber sprechen kann grüß dich
andré hallo simon günstig du bist 1992
in russland geboren in rostov am don das
liegt keine drei autostunden östlich von
mario pohl hast dann studiert am
staatlichen nach meinen auf
konservatorium und ein master in hamburg
gemacht du bist als russisch stämmige
plan ist natürlich gerade im zentrum
einer debatte die lautet wieviel
gesinnungsprüfung ist eigentlich
notwendig gerade als russischstämmiger
künstler in deutschland
eine pauschale bei code finde ich
schlecht also es gibt nämlich ganz viele
künstler die wollen sich auch mit
musikalischen mittel gegen krieg äußern
ich gehöre auch zu diesen musiker und
ich habe ganz viele freunde tja auch so
sind und deshalb ich persönlich bin froh
dass ich nicht noch in mich hinein die
situation befinde wo man mich bei
goutiert ist künstler hast du denn das
gefühl dass du dich in dieser situation
jetzt besonders deutlich politisch
positionieren musst wenn du auftritte
hat öffentlich gesagt ja aber nicht so
dass ich sozusagen von der gesellschaft
gezwungen wenn ich hatte glaube ich ein
erstes konzert das war ein kleines haus
konzertes wird trieb dem tag von krieg
und es war mir einfach persönlich
selbstverständlich ganz wichtig dass ich
bevor ich anfange dass ich sage was ich
denke und dass ich diese musik widmen
und in frieden und und menschen die
jetzt leiden die ukraine und dass es war
einfach mein wunsch und seitdem
eigentlich in jedem konstant egal ob es
ein benefizkonzert ein spendenkonto für
die flüchtlinge oder einfach ein mein
einfach meine konzerte ist ich möchte
jetzt meinen äußern und mach dass du
hast ich kann meinen wie gesagt dass ich
einige russische künstler so ein zitat
direkt für den krieg aussprechen ist
wahnsinn absolut inakzeptabel welche
russischen musikalischen künstler hast
du da vor augen gehabt als zu diesen
satz gesagt hat na ja das ist natürlich
kein geheimnis es gibt ja einen
dirigenten moskauer
akademie oder eine
russische pianist boris beresowski zum
beispiel ich war ganz ehrlich ein großer
fan von diesen musikern aber ich habe
bevor ich das gesagt habe in dem
interview glaube ich zwei tage davor
habe ich in einer tv show in der
russischen fernseher auf youtube gesehen
und das was er sagt da das möchte so gar
nichts zitiert ich kann das so gar nicht
zitieren aber es ist genau das was ich
inakzeptabel findet er bei einem gedacht
in dem moment das war unglaublich groß
handelt ich meine jetzt gibt es in
diesem appell auch eine passage die sagt
das ist halt schwierig ist solche klaren
formulierungen zu fordern weil eben
diese klaren aussagen unter umständen
der person selbst oder ihren angehörigen
freunden arbeitskollegen russland
erheblichen schaden zufügen könnten
verstehst du diese argumentation nicht
auch also dass man als russische pianist
im moment halt auch nicht so eindeutig
stellung beziehen kann
ja schon
besonders ich glaube wenn ich mir
vorstelle man lebt da man heute weiß
drei kinder eine frau muss die schultern
sozusagen
und er versteht das würde das ist jetzt
macht und avocent wir befürchten oder
weiß nicht ob ihr das diese gelegenheit
hat sozusagen oder ist einfach nicht nur
er sondern die ganze familie ist in
gefahr ich möchte es mir nicht ganz
direkt vorstellen aber das könnte man
wahrscheinlich vorstellen dass aus angst
sagen einige entweder nichts oder
sagen nicht klar oder sagen zu wenig
vielleicht noch mal eine musikalische
frage zum abschluss an den experten
sozusagen das jetzt manche opernhäuser
tschaikowsky musik absetzen weil sie
darin einen zu patriotischen klang
empfinden was sagst du dazu ich habe
daran gedacht ich lese dass da ständig
also ich glaube das ist nicht richtig
diese musik zurück auf ski selbst oder
spanien auf der übrigens nach der
revolution 1917 nach usa geflüchtet ist
ich weiß nicht ob man diese musik mit
russland heutzutage und mit putins
russland
assoziieren verknüpfen darf und muss ich
glaube nicht aber andererseits ist es
auch verständlich dass jetzt ein konzert
aus sieg von russische komponisten
vielleicht klingt so dass man weiß nicht
was man dann sagen möchte warum jetzt
vielleicht lieber ich jetzt nicht oder
weniger ist es ist eine sehr schwierige
frage für mich ehrlich gesagt auch ich
stehe jetzt wo vorauswahl für mein
konzert ob ich da unter anderem werke 34
produkten von reinem spielen soll oder
lieber programm ändern muss das ist
jetzt ende frage na ja eine frage die
verbände du selber entscheiden muss aber
die die natürlich eine ist die uns jetzt
alle umtreiben muss man sagen hört man
musik verantwortlich machen kann für
einen politischen gewaltverbrecher das
bleibt zu diskutieren ich danke dir für
deine zeit andré und wünsche dir alles
gute ich danke der vielen dank für die
einladung
dass ein junger kerl ist wirklich gerade
darüber nachdenken muss sein programm zu
ändern und russische musik daraus zu
verbannen ist schon erstaunlich ehrlich
gesagt sogar etwas schockierend aber das
hat natürlich etwas zu tun mit den
debatten die in den letzten wochen
gelaufen sind mit der debatte um die
putin ehe ist dirigenten valery gergiew
oder auch um die top sopranistin anna
netrebko ich freue mich jetzt sehr mit
unserem faz musikkritiker jan brachmann
sprechen zu dürfen
bisher brachten christi herr strauß
haben wir doch zu beginn mal rein in
einen auftritt von anna netrebko nehmen
sie am vorabend des kriegsbeginns am 23
februar in einem luxuriösen
geschäftszentrum in moskau abgehalten
hat
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja lieber herr brachmann bevor wir in
die politischen fragen einsteigen
vielleicht einmal noch mal die
künstlerischen was hat denn die sängerin
anna netrebko aus ihrer sicht
ausgezeichnet musikalisch sie hatte erst
einmal eine starke bühnenpräsenz und sie
war sehr kollegial sie hat mit anderen
sängerinnen und sängern auf der bühne
sehr gut interagiert ich kann mich noch
gut an ihre susanna bei den salzburger
festspielen in der nordsee die figaro
von mozart
erinnern nikolaus harnoncourt hat
dirigiert und anna netrebko sang die
susanna alle witzelten schonen das sei
die hochzeit der anna und nicht ihre
hochzeit des figaro aber es kam ganz
anders im mittelpunkt der inszenierung
stand plötzlich christine schäfer als
cherubino und anna netrebko nahm sich
unglaublich intelligent vom bühnen
verhalten her und sehr kollegial zurück
und fügte sich in diese inszenierung von
claus guth wunderbar ein hinzu kommt
dass sie eine technisch wirklich
perfekte sängerin ist besonders das
italienische petra werde jetzt zunehmend
auch puccini etwas schwerere rollen
wirklich ebenmäßig im klang durch alle
register hinweg man man kann man konnte
sie wirklich bewundert für ihre
technische perfektion nicht unbedingt
für die schärfe ihrer sprache manchmal
aber sie hatte schon einen oder hat sie
eigentlich immer noch einen
herausragenden rang unter den sopranen
dieser welt ja die schärfe ihrer sprache
ästhetisch gesehen hat jetzt einen
politischen beiklang bekommen man hat
lange gewartet auf ein statement eine
distanzierung von ihr zu dem russischen
angriffskrieg noch im september letzten
jahres erzieherin geburtstag ihren
fünfzigsten im kreml gefeiert jetzt hat
sie sich aber distanziert aber das
reicht anscheinend nicht der hamburger
kulturpolitik prostata hat schon
mitgeteilt dass sie dass er diese
distanzierung nicht für glaubwürdig
heißt jetzt sind wir eine situation sie
hat sich distanziert das heißt sie hat
jetzt auftrittsverbot in russland aber
darf auch in europa nicht mehr auftreten
wie schätzen sie das ein
anna netrebko hat sich in der
vergangenheit außerhalb der bühne nicht
unbedingt sehr klug verhalten sie hat ja
schon ich glaube 2016 war das mit
ukrainischen separatisten führen und
deren flagge posierte sie hat den auch
geld überwiesen ich glaube das war die
sogenannte volksrepublik in lugansk sie
hat das ziemlich ohne not getan offenbar
aus freien stücken ich weiß nicht ob sie
dazu angehalten wurde so genau kann man
das wenn man in russland nicht lebt
beziehungsweise nicht einblick hat in
die gesprächskanäle
nie genau entscheiden aber besonders
klug war das nicht anders als waleri
gergiew trägt ja anna netrebko keine
verantwortung für große häuser und für
viele tausend mitarbeiter und sie ist
für sich selbst allein verantwortlich
sie hat auch den österreichischen pass
sie muss nicht unbedingt in russland
leben und das war nicht sonderlich klug
von ihr dass sie das damals getan hat
das war lehre gergiew 2014 die krim an
aktion gutheißen musste steht auf einem
ganz anderen blatt er stand in ganz
anderen verpflichtungen als anna
netrebko das taten aber ist es denn
jetzt anzeigen von intelligenz wenn
trotz dieser distanzierung die new
yorker u-bahn oder auch jetzt in
frankfurt ein konzertveranstalter
trotzdem sagen ja sie hat zwar gesagt
aber es ist nicht glaubwürdig genug wir
lassen sie es trotzdem nicht auftreten
schadet man da nicht wirklich auch einer
künstlerin die sich jetzt nun offensiv
politisch distanziert hat ja das tut man
und das ist auch riskant für anna
netrebko das sieht man ja auch sie ist
in north sea breeze sofort ausgeladen
worden mit der begründung in zeiten wo
man in klaren standpunkt beziehen muss
aber sie die bequemlichkeit westlicher
konzerthäuser vorgezogen vor der
patriotischen solidarisierung mit ihrem
eigenen land und man hat ja an der
wusste jetzt auch nachgeschoben es werde
auch neue publikumslieblinge geben die
die stelle von anderen die treppe im
eigenen land einnehmen können also wenn
sie jetzt diesen schritt gegangen ist
sollte man wirklich darüber nachdenken
die ausgestreckte hand auch anzunehmen
zumindest gespräch mit ihr zu führen und
das hat zum beispiel der intendant der
staatsoper in berlin matthias schulz
auch angedeutet dass er darüber
nachdenkt sie führt von dort nach berlin
wieder zu verpflichten allerdings nicht
ohne vorher mit ihr das persönliche
gespräch zu suchen das finde ich auch
einen gangbaren vernünftigen weg auch
benedikts tampa hatte das ja schon in
baden-baden angedeutet das konzert für
die opernfestspiele am 13 april erstmal
nicht weiter zu planen trotzdem arbeiten
gespräch mit anderen die treppe zu
bleiben das halte ich für die noblere
variante als die von carsten rost wie
sehen sie das denn jetzt überhaupt also
russisch stämmige musiker musikerinnen
es sind es her vor allem aus der
klassischen musik sind angehalten sich
jetzt politisch zu positionieren wie
weit geht denn dass ich meine das wort
der gesinnungsprüfung liegt da natürlich
nicht fern er diese forderungen nach
gesinnungs bekenntnissen sind fahrlässig
und sie sind auch überheblich ich da
spricht eigentlich nur westlicher
moralischer pomp daraus und vielleicht
mehr kann vieles interesse aber keinen
kein moralisches interesse man versucht
das einem empörten publikum gegenüber zu
rechtfertigen dass diese künstler
auftreten können aber bringt die
künstler selbst dadurch unglaublich in
gefahr der russische pianist alexander
mario fehr wir sind kanada ausgeladen
worden er ist 20 jahre alt er war bei
der krim aktion 14 jahre alt den kann
man überhaupt nicht verantwortlich
machen für das was politisch in seinem
land passiert und die pianistin julianna
fdr war die zu den preisträgerinnen
gehört darf jetzt in polen nicht
auftreten ohne dass sie sich vom krieg
und von putin öffentlich distanziert das
kann sie allerdings nicht weil sie
dadurch ihre eltern die noch in russland
leben in gefahr bringt und die müssen
das dann ausbaden und ihr vater ist
schwer krank das ist absolut
unmenschlich so etwas von den künstlern
zu verlangen man man muss bei diesen
bekenntnis zwängen vielleicht
unterscheiden wie die künstler sich
früher verhalten haben aber auch da ist
es im grunde genommen schwierig zu sagen
sie waren bislang putin unterstützer sie
sind es auch jetzt man kann ja nicht
wissen ob dieser krieg für sie nicht
persönlich auch eine zäsur darstellt und
für viele bisherige putin unterstützt
stellt dieser krieg eine zäsur da das
ist bei dem geiger vladimir spivakov der
fall gewesen der immer zu den
sogenannten putin ist in russland
gehörten gehört und sich jetzt vom krieg
distanzierte und auch vom internet beim
intendanten des moskauer bolschoi
theaters wladimir urin der bislang auch
loyal zu seinem präsidenten war aber
dann unmittelbar nach kriegsausbruch
auch einen offenen brief initiiert hat
und sich distanzierte vom krieg das ist
ein unglaubliches risiko was die leute
damit eingehen ja ein risiko für sich
selbst persönlich ein risiko für ihre
familienangehörigen und ein risiko
für die mitarbeiter für die sie
verantwortung tragen ja einen namen
nicht genannt haben dabei ebenfalls
neben gerne von der tepco in der kritik
steht natürlich auch weil er so
prominentes ist hier dokuments ist wie
ist da die lage was wird ihm vorgeworfen
er ist ja eigentlich griechischer
abstammung jetzt richtig weiß ja nicht
wo es erscheint als griechischer
abstammung hat aber die russische
staatsbürgerschaft hat den russischen
pass er hat sein ensemble musica aeterna
das orchester und auch den chor groß
gemacht in perm mit oligarchen geld es
ist eben dank dieser förderung von
oligarchen auch möglich geworden sein
korn westeuropa zu präsentieren mit
wirtschaftlich auch etwas unlauteren
methoden hat preisdumping betrieben er
hat andere ensembles unterbieten können
und dadurch seine aus sammelt
beispielsweise auch bei der
ruhrtriennale lancieren können
inzwischen wird er von der wtb bank
unterstützt es die zweitgrößte bank
russlands die inzwischen auch auf der
sanktionsliste steht und es kommt hinzu
dass er mit seinen aus samels inzwischen
aus perm nach sankt petersburg umgezogen
ist ins ehemalige haus des rundfunks ein
miteigentümer dieses haus des rundfunks
ist die nationale medien gesellschaft zu
deren vorstandsmitglied alina capa war
gehört die geliebte von vladimir putin
die er ja nach nicht bestätigten
gerüchten 2007 auch heiraten wollte nach
der scheidung von seiner frau jetzt muss
man die frage stellen reicht kontakt
schuld schon aus um einen künstler
auszuladen beziehungsweise reicht das
finanzierungsmodell schon aus samples in
russland sind entweder durch oligarchen
oder den staat finanziert beides ist
momentan und tragbar weil die
geschäftsbeziehung einfach aufgrund der
sanktionen abgebrochen sind ich finde so
lange die künstler sich nicht zum krieg
positioniert haben indem sie ihn
unterstützen sie können ja auch
schweigen sich neutral verhalten so
lange sollte man dann eher nach
alternativen finanzierungsmodellen
suchen als die aussahen wie es jetzt zu
bestrafen es gibt ja nur jenseits der
personalien auch inhaltliche reaktionen
auf den klick also mehrere opern in der
schweiz und auch in polen haben
jackowski abende abgesagt keine für
mo'nique hat auch alle jackowski
konzerte jetzt für
den april gecancelt weil sie sagen das
ist nicht projekt ja es gehört sich im
moment nicht diese musik zu spielen ich
meine wenn wir damit anfangen wo sollen
wir da eigentlich aufhören mit musik aus
russland natur aus russland da kann er
ein weites feld aufmachen wenn man sich
die osterfestspiele in baden-baden
anschaut so wird das ja eine durch und
durch russische saison werden da geht
man ja sehr maßvoll um ich glaube man
muss bei einigen werken jetzt etwas
vorsichtig sein und die werke auch
schützen dass sie nicht in einen über
emotionalisierten diskurs hineingerissen
werden und dadurch ideologisch so
aufgeladen werden ursprünglich war ja
mal selber von tschaikowsky im letzten
jahr für die osterfestspiele vorgesehen
das ist ein werk glaube ich dass man
momentan nicht aufführen sollte weil es
alt die kriegerischen
auseinandersetzungen zwischen russland
schweden und der ukraine späten 17
frühen achtzehnten jahrhundert zum
hintergrund hat und da ist es halt
schwierig zu sagen wo positioniert sich
jackowski es gibt ja diskussionen dass
das auch die sicht auf diesen kosaken
führer mazeppa russisch dominiert ist
auch wie sie im westen adaptiert wurde
und wertgeschätzt wird ähnlich ist es
sicherlich auch mit der sinfonie von
schostakowitsch die das massaker an den
juden in der weiber schlug ihr vor 81
jahren thematisiert und wo der text ich
denke ja auch darauf eingeht und wie das
wissen dass an diesem massaker nicht nur
die waffen ss und die wehrmacht
beteiligt war sondern auch ukrainische
und weißrussische nationalisten ich
glaube das sind jetzt werke die eine
zeit lang pausieren sollten bevor man
sich ihnen wieder nüchtern nähern kann
ich sie sind als kunstwerke stark genug
dass sie auch über ihre entstehung
anlässe und das geschichtsbild dass sie
dass sie transportieren hinweg bestand
haben werden aber dass man jetzt ein
grundsätzliches aufführungsverbot für
russische musik verhängt das halte ich
auch für ja geradezu barbarisch dass die
meinung unseres musikkritikers jan
brachmann ich danke ihnen sehr für das
gespräch danke lieber straße
barbarisch und unser musikkritiker die
vorstellung eines grundsätzlichen
aufführungsverbot viel russische musik
und was ist mit dem russischen ballett
gerade ist eine seiner profiliertesten
vertreter in deutschland zurückgetreten
aus familiären gründen wie es offiziell
heißt das dass inoffiziell bedeutet
frage ich jetzt meine kollegin wiebke
hüster unsere tanz und ballett
kritikerin hallo hallo sie malen ja ganz
frisch kamen die nachricht rein aus
münchen dass der chef des staatsballetts
selensky wegen in anführungszeichen
private familiäre angelegenheiten
zurückgetreten ist du hast es ja in den
letzten wochen und tage intensiv
verfolgt gibt uns auch mal eine
einschätzung die man diese begründung zu
verstehen hat das war sehr kurios also
das begann alles mit der kündigung
münchens an gergijew den dirigenten und
im nachklang dessen hat manni gruse
lenski eine stellt das bayerische
staatsministerium für wissenschaft und
kunst hat ihn eingestellt und hat ihn
befragt zu nebentätigkeiten
die er als berater einer putin an kultur
erbe stiftung in russland wahrgenommen
hat die ergebnisse dieser befragung hat
das ministerium allerdings für sich
behalten und man hat eigentlich täglich
seitdem darauf gewartet dass von der
ersten märzhälfte dass sich irgendjemand
mal dazu erklärt dann begann die ballett
festwoche vor einer woche und das war
ebenso kurios weil der hauptgast schon
schon angereist schon eine woche vor der
großen premiere war alexej hat man ski
ein wirklich weltberühmter russische
chor graf frühere bolschoi ballett
direktor der seit vielen jahren in new
york lebt und für das american basierter
haus choreograf ist und er hat dem
bayerischen staatsballett in dieser
spielzeit eben mit premiere zum auftakt
der ballett festwoche ein wundervolles
stück von sich anvertraut nämlich die
bilder einer ausstellung
so und nun war ich mir natürlich drauf
weil rand mansky ist ein aktivist für
die ukraine er hat dort familie freunde
seine berufliche laufbahn hat dort
begonnen und er sammelt auf facebook und
instagram ist kann man auch sehen
wirklich die stimmen prominenter tänzer
die sich gegen den krieg aussprechen und
auf dieser liste fehlte sie ganz
natürlich und hat man sich gedacht kann
alex elwardt mansky der seine produktion
im bolschoi ab sagt seine produktion im
mariinsky ballett ab sagt kann der
wirklich allen ernstes nach münchen an
ein haus combo ihres elends gesicht
weigert sich von putin oder der ukraine
krieg zu distanzieren er hat es gemacht
sie lenski war auch zunächst nicht da
die beiden sind sich aus dem weg
gegangen und jetzt haben ende dieser
ballett woche ist es dann passiert da
dann sie lenski bekannt gegeben am ende
der letzten vorstellung hat das
bayerische staatsballett diese
pressemitteilung raus geschickt dass er
eben aus familiären gründen von seiner
position zurück tritt er ist dann wohl
am ende des trailers vorstellung nach
dem applaus zu den tänzern hinter den
vorhang auf die bühne gegangen und hat
sich mit wegen knappen worten
verabschiedet und war dann weg aber das
ist ein vorgeschobener grund natürlich
privat familie das heißt es ist aus
politischen gründen dass er die sache
jetzt ruhen lässt oder ja das können wir
eben schwer beurteilen da kann man indem
man wirklich überhaupt nicht
hineinschauen ich weiß dass das ballett
selbst gesagt hat als der krieg begann
ja sie lenski sei da gewesen also im
haus gewesen und habe auch mehrfach
geäußert dass er diesen speed ganz
furchtbar finde aber er hat es eben
offiziell nie gemacht nun muss man
wissen wie lenski war bis 2017 2016 hat
er in münchen den job angetreten als
ballettdirektor und er war bis 2017 noch
direktor in moskau der zweitgrößten
ballettkompanie moskaus nämlich dass
stanislawski
demirovic datango balletts und er hat
natürlich dort in nähe zur politischen
macht gearbeitet und er hat es dann
aufgegeben und alle dachten ja okay da
kommt jetzt nach münchen und ist froh
dass seine familie und er sicherheit
sind vielleicht abschließend wien
verliert werden jetzt die deutsche
ballettszene mit igor selensky was ist
das für einen künstler gewesen er hat
das muss man wirklich sagen nach den 16
jahren mit ihren lischka als
ballettdirektor in münchen er hat das
kompanie niveau so entscheidend
gesteigert und er hat ganz fantastische
gastsolisten immer wieder nach münchen
gebracht aber er hat auch seine eigene
münchner company wirklich zu ganz großen
leistungen geführt die haben jools
getanzt von balanchine ganz wundervoll
und ich muss auch sagen ich würde es ein
bisschen lächerlich von kollegen in den
medien zu sagen ja
natürliches lenski irgendwie putin da
hat man ja gleich gesehen weil er 2016
mit spartacus einen ganz großartigen
sowjetischen ballett ist eine erste
spielte begonnen hat oder kann ich nur
sagen so ein quatsch das ist ein ganz
tolles ballett und das hat überhaupt
nichts mit stalinismus oder so zu tun
was ich so im größeren bild interessant
finde was mir auch der ausland
petersburg geflüchtete eli avivi der
tänzer und choreograf des mariinsky
bestätigt hat sind die folgen für eine
erneute abgrenzung denn was wir gesehen
haben in den vergangenen 20 jahren war
ja endlich einfluss aus dem westen in
den osten und zurück es sind ja
britische und amerikanische tänzer sogar
beim bolschoi bei marines die auch
solisten geworden und es gab wirklich
austausch und das bolschoi ballett hat
einen hans van manen ballettabend und
und dieser wundervolle austausch der
stattgefunden hat der für alle in der
tanzwelt extrem produktiv und schön war
der glaube ich da kommt jetzt zu einem
erliegen das war unsere tanks kritiker
würden wie gelöster vielen dank für das
gespräch sehr gern
nun habe ich hier den mann vor mir
sitzen der gerade keine russische musik
hören will andrej melik der bekannt
gewordene botschafter der ukraine in
deutschland herr botschafter unlängst
haben sie die teilnahme an einem
benefizkonzert des bundespräsidenten
abgesagt weil dort russische solisten
aus traten im interview mit dem
tagesspiegel haben sie dann gesagt dass
das konzert aus ihrer sicht zitat ein
klares signal richtung moskau vielleicht
sogar richtung putin gewesen sein zu
zeigen ich halte hier die stellung
glauben sie wirklich dass ein
benefizkonzert so einen effekt haben
kann jede handlung auch ein konzert hat
ein bestimmtes ziel und hat eine
bestimmte wirkung also für mich als
trainer aber auch als botschafter
ist immer noch nicht klar wieso um mit
uns eine solidaritäts gäste oder mit uns
diese solidarität zu zeigen dass
erforderlich war das eben als ein
versöhnungs gäste zu machen ukraine und
russen sitzen zusammen musizieren
beklatschen einander und haben spaß an
dem geschehen so für mich war das
befremdlich muss ich sagen denn solange
diese krieg und zwar in dieser
grausamkeit tobt auf unserem boden kann
man sich gar nicht vorstellen dass man
nicht nur miteinander musiziert oder
miteinander etwas gemeinsames hat
sondern erst nach dem krieg natürlich
wird diese personen kommen und und wir
hoffen dass das dass diese versöhnung
auch schnell von statten geht aber auch
da muss man realistisch bleiben nach dem
zweiten zweiten weltkrieg es hat
jahrzehnte gedauert bis zwischen
frankreich und deutschland wieder eine
neue partnerschaft entstanden sind
mindestens zwei jahrzehnte und ich
glaube dass in unserem fall dass
vielleicht noch länger dauern wird also
das wird das wird wahrscheinlich nicht
eine sondern zwei generationen benötigen
damit man überhaupt lust hat einfach
etwas
mit mit den russen zu tun und deswegen
war das 1 1 voreilige schritt das war in
ein schritt der für mich persönlich aber
dasselbe echo gab es auch in der ukraine
dann auch dieses konzert hat in der
ukraine sehr hohe wellen geschlagen und
ich habe keine einzige reaktion in
meiner heimat gehört wo gesagt wurde oh
du hättest vielleicht doch lieber
hingehen kann aber einer der teilnehmer
einer der russischen pianisten war ja
evgeny kissin der sich als einer der
ersten vom krieg distanziert hat also
jetzt niemand der im ruf steht ein putin
a mensch zu sein und der andere der
bariton rodion progov ist nur in
lausanne geboren lebte lange in der usa
also schadet man eigentlich nicht gerade
den potenziellen widerstand den es auch
in der russischen gesellschaft jetzt
gibt und geben muss wenn man solche
leute dann mit einem sozusagen affront
abwerteten sagt mit russen kann ich im
moment nicht an einem tisch sitzen das
spielt keine rolle ich meine der
bundespräsident hat das absichtlich
organisiert das stand auf der webseite
dass der russische pianist der russische
bariton
auftreten werden und der ukrainische
botschafter da sitzen sollte und die
beiden buben sollte das ist etwas was
was sie und was was die deutschen gar
nicht verstehen kann und das kann ich
auch
nachvollziehen dass sie das nicht
verstellen können denn sie erleben nicht
diesen krieg ja sie haben nicht diese
emotionen sie können uns im moment und
da meine ich nicht nur jetzt die
öffentlichkeit in deutschland sondern
auch die bundesrepublik man kann uns gar
nicht also verstehen wie schlimm wie
schlecht es uns gerade geht und deswegen
wird es keine konzerte geben es wird
keine gemeinsame veranstaltung geben es
wird keine hand ständiges geben es wird
auch keinen blick geben in richtung
russland um einfach zu nicken dass das
wir wollen mit diesem russland ob das
sein
antlitz von putin hat oder von einem
fokus auf oder gießen oder egal von wem
nichts gemeinsames haben solange die
bomben auf ukrainische städte fallen
kann ein klassisches musikkonzert ein
sympathie signal für den krieg sein kann
als man ihn oft rede wirklich verdächtig
wirken was ist mit der trennung von
kunst und politik was ist mit dem
grundsatz im zweifel für den angeklagten
schon jetzt werden russische künstler
von westlichen kunst organisationen mit
vergeltungsmaßnahmen konfrontiert die
würden sie etwa von einer chinesischen
organisation getätigt mit ziemlicher
sicherheit als totalitär angesehen
würden und doch will nichts ausruf das
gemeinsame konzerte fehl am platz sein
solange russische bomben auf ukrainische
städte fallen halt noch nach vielleicht
finden sie ja dagegen noch bessere
argumente als ich in jedem fall freue
ich mich über kritik und anregungen von
ihnen und danke sehr dass sie heute mit
dabei waren
[Musik]